please join me in a spirit of prayer
holy one
your words are sweeter than honey may
the words of my mouth and the
meditations of all our hearts be
acceptable in your sight O God for you
every week the internet seems to come
one step closer to the grand unification
of all memes and trends and trolls on
Friday afternoon the angry baby meme
fused with partisan politics when a post
from Jezebel featuring photos of Mitt
Romney holding unhappy babies plastered
itself across my Facebook and Twitter
feeds it prompted reactions and
amusement and outrage from across the
political spectrum including one might
imagine the babies themselves whether
you're registered to vote in this year's
election or you aren't there really is
no way to escape the media wide
political frenzy as long as you
currently reside within the United
States with the election itself only a
little over a month away and the debates
right around the corner the Obama and
Romney campaigns are approaching fever
pitch and it's visible everywhere I
looked briefly at a projected electoral
map earlier this week and it struck me
with its similarity to the electoral map
in any other year the reliably red
states were read the reliably blue
states were blue and the usual swing
states were some shade of purple as much
as both campaigns continued to talk
about their attempts to win the
independent vote the Latino vote or the
african-american vote the lines seem to
have been drawn already of course this
situation is no different from any of
the other recent elections but this year
as with every other major election year
the stakes feel high are you on the
right side or the wrong side are you on
the winning team or the losing team will
you save the country or will you allow
it to crumble to pieces taking the world
along with it it's difficult to choose a
side when the consequences feel so dire
but it's easier to make sense of life
when you can see a defined patchwork of
red
blew it simplifies things a great deal
after all once you determine that your
one color in particular let's say blue
you find yourself with a nice list of
all the things that blue identifying
people believe you also have a list of
all the stereotypes concerning red
identified people and this affects how
you understand them for better or for
worse belonging to a group affects how
we define others and how we define
ourselves the boundaries are drawn the
rules for life are written as much as we
enjoy talking about diversity and
inclusivity there's a part of our
humanists that prefers to see sharp
contrasts it gets tired of constantly
hearing the other side of the story more
often than we'd like to admit we let
this side of ourselves get lazy as a
result it feels like a violation when
Outsiders act as if they are inside our
group this type of boundary violation is
of primary concern to Jesus and His
disciples in today's reading from the
Gospel of Mark very early in the book of
Mark Jesus disciples had learned that
following Jesus meant believing in the
good news he had to share it also came
with special responsibilities in the 3rd
chapter of Mark which is well before
today's reading Jesus led twelve of his
followers up a mountain there he named
them apostles a word that literally
means messengers sent to carry the good
news to all people he also gave them the
authority to cast out demons something
they had only seen Jesus perform
successfully from that point onward the
Twelve Apostles would be known as
followers of Jesus because they invoked
his name as they cast out demon
themselves only Jesus could confer this
kind of power and only those who were
truly his followers could wield it it's
a major issue then when John reports to
Jesus that he's seen someone casting out
demons in Jesus name John doesn't say
whether this person was a Roman a Jew or
someone who had been standing in a crowd
watching Jesus teach and heal whoever he
was he had been using Jesus name to do
work that only the Apostles were
authorized to do it would have been a
bit like discovering someone practicing
medicine without a license
John reports to Jesus that he made
certain that this amateur Exorcist
practicing without any affiliation to
Jesus himself was stopped immediately
thanks to John the integrity of what it
meant to follow Jesus has been preserved
outsiders have no authorization to do
Jesus work there was a proper procedure
for becoming a real follower of Jesus a
real member of the community except that
those were John's rules of community not
Jesus's rules Jesus's response to John
is one of the few places in the Bible
where he actually invokes Gehenna often
translated as hell a place of eternal
fire with hyperbolic anger Jesus tells
John that by stopping the person casting
out demons in Jesus name John did not
preserve the fragile Jesus community
instead he actively thwarted the faith
of the one who was beginning to believe
in the good news of Jesus good news
strong enough that Jesus very name had
the power to cast out demons according
to Jesus graphic analogy it would be
better to suffer maimed than to cause
others to stumble
it would be better to risk compromised
boundaries than to restrict Jesus work
of healing and justice to insiders we
read Jesus admonition to John today
because of course it also applies to us
claiming that we are the only ones who
know the good news of the gospel the
only ones who can speak about God's
dream of justice and healing for the
world and the only ones who can do that
work is like insisting upon living with
a necrotizing limb refusing a
life-saving amputation because of our
own denial or fear or even vanity even
though the gangrene will soon turn fatal
the problem of avoiding the unsettling
consequences of the breath of God's work
is timeless one of the oldest parts of
the Hebrew Bible records it when Moses
receives a report of two people
prophesying who were not among the
select group in the tent of meeting
initially chosen to prophesy and of
course we face it even today we take
seriously the words of those who are
authorized to teach us and preach to us
because they have spent long years in
graduate school or have built impressive
resumes while we look askance at the
contribution of the freshmen in the
graduate seminar we sign on with a
company or a college or a political
party or a religion yes even the faith
we proclaim in this church and we become
prone to ignoring sources of God's good
news beyond it what is it risk when we
let the red and blue political patchwork
become purple or share public space with
the University of New Haven or
Quinnipiac or Gateway Community College
or attention baat services or break
exclusive membership wide open could it
be that we're afraid we will risk losing
the certainty of knowing good from bad
inside from outside moral from amoral
qualified from unqualified where God is
from where God is not
Jesus walks among us with good news but
no Bible no part of any Bible suggests
that good news is easy news Jesus words
to John full of frustration and anger
were probably far from easy for
well-intentioned john to hear jesus
words to us today are similarly
difficult the gospel does not exist only
among us only within the walls of this
church or even only among christians
Jesus calls us as his followers to
listen to all who are working in his
name the name of peace justice and hope
if you are a Democrat this might mean
listening really listening to
Republicans maybe even libertarians if
you're a mainline Protestant by
background it might mean taking the
Evangelical Protestant tradition
seriously listening for what it has to
offer if you are a Christian
this may mean listening to people of
other faiths and people of no faith for
all of us in this Chapel it means
working with our Jewish and Muslim and
Buddhist sisters and brothers which is
all the more important because members
of each of these faith groups use this
very chapel for their religious
observances at least once a year
we are called not just to do God's work
not just to listen to people unlike
ourselves but to join them
in doing what we recognize as the work
God calls us to do serving those
overlooked by society speaking truth to
power and acting as midwives for the in
breaking of the kingdom of God God's
work does not depend on us alone if we
think that we proclaim the gospel here
but we neither work for it nor listen
for it when we walk out each Sunday at
11:30 then there is no good news among
us but if we listen for how others
without what we might see as our
qualifications if we listen for how they
are doing Jesus work of justice service
and inclusion then the good news is
alive among us and throughout the world
in this season of division when we split
one alternative from another when we
become irritated even with our friends
when their opinions differ from our own
let us remember Christ's work is done by
all people on both sides of the aisle
and beyond it
we don't have any way to identify who is
qualified to do this work and yes it is
more than a little unsettling to imagine
it being done by outsiders people we
don't even know but the God who calls us
into this unsettled space is also the
God who fills it with good news may we
all be salted with fire the radical
faith to recognize the gospel preached
everywhere around us
every day